[Music]
a little bit of work man that don't
scare us i get up i go hard like i'm
george harris make plays break lanes
push way
[Music]
[Music]
we got a very special episode of fight
night flashbacks my boy robin black is
here you're a mma encyclopedia when we
actually pick three fights you sent us
about 300. so we're doing our best we're
going to cover three here we kind of go
for finishes otherwise it's too long of
a show yeah now you decide to kick it
off
with now i will say this one my least
favorite fights for many reasons but
this is ronda rousey versus holly holm
and i this is at the time was the
biggest gate in ufc ever in australia
and i remember i was watching this with
my at the time my girlfriend now my wife
we were watching this
in um
we were in uh napa valley at a hotel
drinking wine drinking wine and i made
sure that they put the ufc on for me
and uh you know yeah yeah so i wanted to
select it
not because
i have a connection to this story
because i remember dana joe had
recommended me to dana white who
flew me to vegas and he at the time was
like we want to hire you and he was
asking me how this fight's going to go
and i was explaining to him what holly
would try to do to keep distance and i
even made a breakdown that he tweeted
out and that she would try to set up a
head kick
and so the whole process of it was kind
of wild but also i look at it because
this in no way undermines any of the
brilliant things rhonda and that's and
and you know a couple of the fights i
selected that i thought about them that
way people try to rewrite history what
ronda was the best in the environment at
the time one every woman fighting ever
should thank her correct because they
all exist in the in the ufc because of
russia because of ronda that is for the
rest of her life she should take pride
in that but also
she was the best in the environment of
the world and nobody's asking you to be
the best basketball player or fighter 10
years from now they're asking you to be
the best in the reality of the world
she's the hoist gracie of women's fights
gracie if he fought gsp would have got
destroyed but boyce gracie at that time
during the 90s 93 matter of fact in
denver that was the best they had to
offer so people are comparing hoist
grace or rhonda to the fighters now
shevchenko amanda yeah it's irrelevant
it's just not relevant she doesn't do
this now and it's not relevant at this
time people will then talk about how she
boxed or didn't box or head movement or
edmond or any of these things they're
irrelevant in those nights on those
crazy performances in big venues with a
million people watching when they
created women's fighting because of you
she went in and mike tyson to people
threw him on the ground knocked out
somebody for the throw just
created armbars on uh katz and ghana
that thing that she did on that night
these were transcendentally brilliant
performances and they're forever agreed
yes cemented in
male or female yeah and i with ronda
rousey she uh trained with my juice to
coach henry uh here on gracie and who
are brilliant the best i [ __ ] love
you so she's training with them and i
remember you know they're going over you
know basic moves that she knew
and then um they were showing armbar
stuff and he had tenor gracie dude he he
grew up in diapers doing arm bars and he
goes ronna show me your arm bar she does
like like nothing does it and i'm i've
seen him with the highest level black
belts and he'll tweak and he goes good
yeah and then she walks up and i go what
do you mean good yeah it's like there's
that's the best we've ever seen
her creativity goes i ca i don't the way
her mind works
especially in the transitions and the
way she rolls he goes i don't understand
yeah she's she goes she's at such a high
level i have nothing to add and i think
that the first time i went holy [ __ ] i
had a i was so coming up i fought i
managed fighters i did anything i could
do to learn about about this thing and
try to really see it from all sides and
i had a fighter named nick denis who i
got to the ufc or he got himself to the
ufc and i talked to and i was talking to
sean shelby and i said i don't know if
i'm buying this this ronda rousey thing
this was before that
uh and then he was she was fighting
sarah kaufman who's a friend and i know
sarah really well and i've been around
sarah and i commentated her fights
and then when she went in and she like
put sarah somewhere got a grip then a
throw then an armbar it's over the issue
is that what you don't realize what
people don't see when they see that each
of those things is a fight correct so
you me grabbing your wrist and keeping
that is a fight yes sir doesn't want
that to happen exactly then the position
to get into the thing that is normally a
fight correct then the next thing all of
those she just annihilated and sarah's
brilliant she's a brilliant martial very
tough she's a brilliant also remember to
sarah you got to remember sarah you name
any fighter liz carmouche
they were the best of the best of the
best the number one contenders but
remember their entire camp was defending
armbars and
and that's where we come to to that's
beautifully uh transitions to this
that's where we come to holly holm and i
remember looking at it and if you're
trying to defend an
she spent what was she 26 at this time
27 something like that so she'd spent 22
years of her life doing an arbor you can
spend nine weeks defending an r bar but
that's pointless right
so the yeah the goal is not figure out
how to defend at our bar it's like well
she's going to throw you well the goal
isn't figure out how to not get thrown
the goal is to figure out how to not get
touched correct and knocking around yeah
and by not getting close
by using your feet so if whether it's
khabib or rhonda or anyone if somebody
wants to get you there and do their
thing they have to
they have to
they're smashing you in a position to do
that they've got to keep you down and
they've got to get you down and to do
that they've got to get a hold of you
and to do that they gotta they gotta
vaporize the gap between you and that's
that's the thing and that's the fight
and that's where i was like that's what
holly then i watched holly holm's first
couple fights and i before this and she
actually they looked like dress
rehearsals for ronda rousey she fought
backing up that's what it was that's
what it was greg jackson and winkle john
i've never spoken to them about about it
but i reckon have you spoken never you
talked to them at the same time talking
about their entire game plan was to beat
ronda rousey they knew she could beat
these girls she could go forward and do
her thing they knew it was a dress
rehearsal just to get to ronda rousey
yep and at that time i was watching
those fights and and i was um
like oh my god that's what this is she
was fighting backing up she was fighting
moving her feet moving laterally keep
maintaining the gap and she didn't
destroy those girls she she fought ronda
rousey and made that fight work and so
i'm coming into this and i did it a
breakdown of it at the time and i was
like you know there are four real ranges
of combat which i thought
after spending years of analyzing coming
up with a a way to frame you know chest
to chest and then and then the pocket
and then
the the tight circle and then the
outside kicking range i was like wow
this is wow then i've sort of defined it
and kind of made broke that all through
and made some circles and then you know
a year later i went and read some bruce
lee stuff and that dude had those four
ranges in the 70s
yeah and so like you you never really
discover or invent anything it's already
there right but but then you know it's
truthful right and i was like so i built
this kind of thing and explained this
would be the goal and this is how you
would try to beat the and rondo when you
say the best fighter in the world again
people will try to discredit and go well
she didn't wasn't this or was only that
or whatever but that is nonsense yeah at
the time nobody she was the greatest and
it doesn't matter if she'd be the
greatest today or 10 years earlier
although 10 years earlier she would have
been
it mattered at the time and she was and
then and holly came in with that plan
yes she knew what she did mike
yeah remember this is also the biggest
gate ever
man isn't that nice
it's been beat now i think i think izzy
and whitaker beat this number by now
there's hannah gracie there he'll just
tell you about
yeah but she was
there's something about her too like
she's
not just the performance but and that's
you know connor tyson all these people
it isn't just what they do when they
perform it's who somehow they're
compelling there's something about them
that we're compelled by and she's all
her stories yeah yeah the story is so
nuts and then also the thing that i
think made ronda and outliers
you know again
male female i've never met somebody so
mentally and you see that they talk
about the they talk about the the kobe
mentality yeah i would say kobe had
herman
that's how much of a savage is yeah just
the the pain she could endure whether
it's you know in life or physically and
training you're just like
she's an alien dude yeah and so holly
holm was at the time a boxing champion
that had come over to mma and all and
kickboxing uh champion but and i love
her i'm like obsessed i think she's a
brilliant martial artist i've been a
monster fan and yet we're still talking
about rhonda that's what we're talking
about and she
won that's how powerful she was right
yeah again for for holly and what a
mastermind greg jackson and winkle john
where she's really close with wing hill
john yes
kind of who made her with this her
striking with kicking
you know
again it was dress rehearsal
to have the mindset to have dressed for
a year
multiple other people and they're
dangerous too and you're fighting a
different fight then you should fight to
defeat them imagine having that
mentality
you know how he goes back there like in
the in the locker room to go you know
what the goal is here yeah we know you
can march forward and knock her out
we're not doing that no we're not doing
that dude she's right number one
practice yeah for this this the goal is
here tonight is just a dress rehearsal
exactly it's probably about the
mentality
and you have to believe in it right and
and rhonda because of her experience
here she is certain she's going to win
because the greats are like that the
greats and the greats at these points of
their life it's like the certainty that
they're going to win has worked every
other time so she's coming in here and
holly even this this 700 underdogs yeah
i actually uh this was the last time i
ever bet money uh because it changes the
way i ever bet money i'm fighting
because it changes the way i look at
fighting and the way i look at fighting
is my career and my passion but i made 2
200
oh uh that's gonna ask if you better
three hundred dollars uh or two hundred
dollars on holly inside the distance
jesus christ yeah and then i was like
and it was cool but then i was like wait
a second my perspective changes when
i've got money on it and i can't change
my perspective because i love bias yeah
i'd be biased but i also love this you
know mine is 1200 yeah yeah that's how
big of a deal she was i know and and she
was worth that was accurate that was
accurate yeah i mean it doesn't matter
how you try to rewrite history on this
night that was accurate yeah she should
have won the fight yeah looking back
yeah so but if we remember again like if
you're trying to defend the armbar
you're screwed so what you've got to do
is prevent
you um you have to prevent her from
grabbing you and hit her and continue to
hit her while keeping your feet moving
to maintain the gap and you know back
here
people didn't talk about distance even
the term distance management didn't
really exist in fighting you know how
terminology constantly changes what we
see how we relate to it the idea of of
managing space just wasn't part of the
conversation not just of us who talk
about fighting but in gems
yeah i think the only person who was
aware of distant management was uh gsp
yeah yeah and the way he used to use his
jab and set up the takedowns because you
see ronda just marching forward
with a technician holly where that's not
what you want to do no but you look at
what are you going to do because you
have to close the space right but holly
is going to beat you with footwork see
she's pushing her the cage two or three
punches if she can get a hold of her
she's going gonna throw her take her
down and arm bar her arm off and that's
her mentality i'm gonna you know i'm
gonna win all the the micro battles and
then do it but holly look at her foot
with the way she's moving so she's not
as good at judo she's not a good as good
at throws she's not a good as good at
grappling but she can be better at
footwork because she has a lifetime
event
and you see holly just kind of you can
see it early on obviously we know the
outcome of the fight but you see it
early on she's just tagging her although
rhonda's a banshee yeah
no fear
again it's like you can't rewrite
history rhonda was a was brilliant and
her mind was good and like you said like
her colby colby or kobe had a ronda
rousey mentality that's real that's real
look at it now so she has an overhook
and she has the hand so that's better
yeah you better beat this or it's going
to be too late so holly does and then
she rhonda comes back in again look at
her lighten her up there yeah now and
that's giving holly confidence there
yeah also for rhonda everybody else was
already out by now because rights were
all over correct she gets you there
you're getting down yeah for rhonda here
it has to be a little bit of like okay
i'm dealing with a different animal yes
but what oof yeah and that's nice yeah
against a high a severe boxer right but
at a second yeah yeah at the time for
sure and maybe today still you know like
chef chen codes of jesus a genius yeah i
think chef chang as far as technical
wise
man or woman yeah
to be honest like and people will
somehow reference her last fight as
somehow evidence against this but rose
is one of the best too rose is one of
the great strikers that's ever fought in
in mixed martial arts cages and look at
it right over there
yeah so here you might be screwed
rhonda's stepping over but she's got
she's found answers and she's fatigued
her ever so slightly and also rhonda
here is so dangerous because those are
unorthodox setups i forgot about that
moment actually yeah i forgot about it
again this is another token in holly's
bank account going all right took me
down got out of it against the wall over
under got out of it so it's just it's
it's the investments that's right in her
confidence yep and it's all raising it's
getting interesting
and she keeps moving she knows just when
to strike you know she plays with the
the space and the gap and manipulates
the negative space the little void
between them
and yeah it's getting better for her and
it's getting slightly worse for rhonda
yes
you know
um and look at holly just so focused not
really even breathing hard and rhonda's
giving him marching forward yeah and all
the way out right and now now backing up
again yeah that check hooks yeah and
then
trying to talk about this she grabbed
that wrist i remember faraz at the time
saying to me like i just never seen that
she's punching and she grabs the wrist
in the punch you just never see that
that was how badly rhonda wanted that
grip and got it but also for rhonda all
she needs is that wrist and it's games
wrist goes to arm arm goes to body body
goes down
yeah
that's credit to her how brilliant she
would
name any other fighter today working
yeah all they need is a wrist and this
thing is over that's right at the
highest level nobody yeah and again at
this time in this environment with the
living organism that is fighting the way
it was rhonda was the best ever at this
time and that that that left hand that
straight left is landing every single
and she's still going forward she still
wants it right but but and it's also a
psychological thing it's like for some
people the way
through is forward forward push more
harder harder harder and yes and that
worked always and it was beautiful as
why she was what she was but sometimes
oh she wobbled her there she had a good
she did and she almost went for it and
here that that's a crazy moment and that
was rehearsed this one there's tony
hinchcliffe in the back standing up you
had to be working on that for a year or
two as well to when rhonda gets that
position turn it against her especially
as a striker but that's a mindset thing
too the idea like we we call something
take down defense it's actually just a
term we use truthfully you don't give
yourself one objective you might hurt
her you might reverse her you might you
get on top take down defense we is a
term we use but it's not really accurate
you shouldn't have a single objective
holly's objective there was actually
reverse you and because yeah yeah
the overall even in the nfl it's all
these little battles was the center the
nose guard right there's all the
linebacker the fullback there's all
these little battles going on
the ufc there's all these little battles
everything like we look at the grand
scheme where it's this overall fight but
just holly reverse and that take it
around that's a win yes that's money in
the base yeah and it's you know and so
holly at this point has established that
this will work we know what rhonda's
going to do which is what we expected
her to do which means we were accurate
she's faster tougher hits harder and is
even better than we expected but we
still i think we won the round that's
what you'd be thinking if you're holly
that left is connecting all day early on
and lands and out right and this is
normal now oh i forgot about that too
it's so fun to watch these again oh dude
i haven't seen this fight since i saw it
live yeah yeah it's amazing rhonda did
better in that round than i remember
even and it's and again
i love holly holm and i respect it so
it's only a minute here until this
happens but we're talking about rhonda
because she was special correct when we
talk about the narrative people go oh
rhonda was chinny yeah how many times
have we seen ronnie get hit in the chin
by holly holm yeah
and keep coming forward to marching
forward like a tank
left hand
yeah left hands now and no she hasn't
once thrown one single high kick though
no i know all the set up yeah it was
very smart that's sideways they're
throwing low kicks and and
level kicks here but on the kick ronda's
kind of turned and it's a moment that
holly's thrown a thousand kicks yeah
yeah you got to be discouraged but this
woman still wants to go forward but it's
a moment rhonda's actually slightly
turned i remember it very clearly and
it's a rare moment but holly and and
and you know the people around her would
have thrown that kick from that position
thousands of times and whether it was
planned or not right here and
you know that's heavy man it's heavy
yeah i gotta be honest you know when you
said you want to watch this fight i
could dude that was one of the darkest
days for me like even though you know
ryan i didn't speak for years before
that before this happened just the
downfall the magnitude of this and it's
like you're watching
one of the greatest ever do it and it's
it's hard it's finally caught up to work
yeah yeah
the world changes slightly and everybody
else studies you and and this is an
inevitability for almost everybody
except for floyd and very few very
outliers john jones the outlier but in
general this is what happens is like she
goes what happened so yeah it's even you
know it's tragic
like you look at colin kaepernick right
and i know i keep referencing the nfl
but you look at colin kaepernick who
took the nfl by stone for the first two
years took him to the the what the the
the nfc championship in the super bowl
and then what happens is they have the
off season and the coaches sit down go
all right what's his weak points
we're going to force him to do this yeah
and if he can't do that he's not going
to win football games so with ronda
the jackson team for uh yeah
what are we doing here we are here to
win we we've got somebody like holly
that isn't just here for the ride she's
here to win and if we're gonna win we're
gonna have to target the the top one and
rhonda was the top one yeah
yeah and then and she's sliding there's
a little drive by boom yeah yeah and and
it is wonderful she's never been in that
situation where she's getting out struck
she's getting hit but aren't working
she's fatigued she's going forward and
dude gets kicked in the neck here's the
thing about that kick you know it's not
a michael chandler's situation holly has
thrown that yeah 50 000 times that's her
bread and [ __ ] buttermilk yeah that
left hand is what she does that left
high kick is definitely what she has yes
a hundred percent and i i don't know
rhonda very well personally i was always
a fan and still am she's now married to
has a child does she have a child yeah
and as a wwe performer yeah and i hope
she's really happy and i hope that that
moment was you know experiencing it
seeing the world you get hated even
though you're people hate you for
something they think you are not who you
really are and going through all of that
yeah
and i hope that that that actually is a
part of her story that's a part a
positive part today because sometimes it
can be losing can really make you a
better person
and then also i think you know then she
goes on with that fight amanda nunes
which i wish she never did yeah and
there were so many red flags if you're a
ronda fan you're doing that fight
because yeah and i am rhonda loved the
media and when i knew she wasn't in the
right frame of mind taking that fight
when for the first time ever dana who
they pride themselves on marketing media
yeah dana goes no she's not doing any
interviews that went that's not like
rhonda yeah ronda loves this yeah yeah
yeah yeah i went oh she's she's in a
dark place yeah and then you see that
fight and you're just like yeah yeah
yeah yeah if you're wrong oh yeah and i
am and i will always be and i'll always
appreciate it and uh
it's just what it is right like we're
not always going to win everything we
don't get to write the end of our story
but whatever happens there's a way that
it becomes a big
everything hurt pain failure loss
success whatever can make you better you
can look back at it even if all it does
is make you see the way she performs as
a wwe performer differently or the way
she does business differently or the way
she frames thinking differently the way
she's a mother differently you can
become your life can improve through
these things and we learn it by watching
it and i know our next fight
it's eddie alvarez and connor and and
eddie did that listen safety is numero
uno in the shop household listen you
need that break in protection you just
don't need any company though you need
simply safe home security that's right
man simply safe is there for you guys
it's the protection you need how about a
little story for you this is josh's
story all right a simply safe customer
in indiana a few months ago he fell
asleep with pizza rolls still in the
oven i like your pizza roll myself the
most dangerous thing is the inside
filling it's
hot lava but that's not this story all
right this could have been a disaster
you fall asleep you got those hot lava
pizza rolls in the oven all right listen
that thing catches on fire thousands of
dollars in damages all right his kitchen
his home's on fire luckily for our
friend josh he has simply safe that's
right simply safe it's equipped with
everything to prevent break-ins smoke
detectors sniffs out the fires for you
he started awake to the sound of a 95
decibel alarm from his simply safe base
station seconds later you got a call
from simply say professional monitoring
all right the pizza rolls didn't make it
that's the shame in this story but josh
did he believes simply save probably
saved his life that night but he's
pretty upset about the pizza rolls
that's his own issues i've been upset
too
but they have a deal right now anyway be
safe out there man if you fall asleep
when uh pizza rolls or break-ins
safety's number one protecting people
when their guard is down is just one of
the reasons more than 4 million people
use and love simply safe i have it i
swear by it all right simply safe system
they have 24 7 professional monitoring
all right you always have someone
looking out for you plans cost under a
dollar a day one dollar a day with no
long-term contracts or hint fees ever
you can customize the perfect system for
your crib in just a few minutes at
simply safe.com
go today and claim a free indoor
security camera plus twenty percent off
with interactive monitoring go to
simplysafe.com shop it actually really
hurt me to do this one uh because i love
eddie alvarez so much
he's my guy
hardcore fan yeah eddie alvarez on the
forums was known in seoul church as the
underground kids because he's the
undergraduate philly's finest and he was
such a monster bellator champion yeah
you know when we talk about his fights
and
he fought in pride yeah yeah yeah
now like he's so true the truest you
know and he would suffer to win later in
life he found that
maybe he doesn't have to but at the time
he took pride and i made a scale it was
called the sap alvarez scale that
analyzed how tough you could be what you
were willing sap bob sapp on the bottom
eddie alvarez on the top
no disrespect to bob's happy but a
little bit but yeah but i mean bob would
show up
yeah and that's okay i'm not most people
who judge him would never even step in
the thing but as soon as he got hurt
he'd be like you know where that's from
the dwight howard him yeah he was like
built like tarzan yeah you know jane
yeah and you know but but uh but the
reason we got to look at this feels
hilarious yeah at the sap alvarez scale
you know i've been doing this for such a
long time and i'm such an obsessive and
i'm so into it and i want to look at it
differently and i know there's so much
magic in these moments that we don't
necessarily look at because we have a
very structured language and way that we
do these things but yeah sap alvarez
scale is a fun one and eddie alvarez i
was celebrating him but on this night
again conor mcgregor this is a level of
performance of any kind singing dancing
acting fighting football that is rare
one of the great performances of all
time yeah and i i think conor would have
beat anybody on this night it's not a
knockout of the obviously this version
of connor would have beat any single 155
or walk in the earth on this night on
that this night at this time
that where there's no one on earth that
could beat gay guards muslims agree i
agree and i think it's such a shame that
ufc won't play ball with bellator i get
it from a business standpoint yeah the
only real 85 fight i'm desperate to see
on planetary yeah
is just such a beast man yeah if you
pause this just for a second i i talked
to eddie a lot about this fight and in
retrospect he's like and and he knows
this and and he's a real
student of fighting and combat and stuff
but he's like i just couldn't perform
but
it is
partly because of how brilliantly conor
is performing that creates that dynamic
that psychologically
he knew conor was fast and explosive and
powerful but he didn't realize he was
that fast and also the way it went from
his hip to his face he was i've never
seen anything like it in real time i
couldn't track it yeah it's almost like
yeah you know and then you start falling
behind and then you start feeling
frustrated and anxious and
better yeah
and he's inflating it's all happening
at this time he was literally writing
the life he wanted creating the life he
wanted for himself which was why it was
so amazing again people will rewrite
history you know he never defended this
he blah blah blah it doesn't matter on
this night this is as great a
performance as you'll ever see in combat
or or most any performance and as you
talked about on the the sit down with me
is you know connor spoke to you about
how this fight's going to go down yeah
if you if you see in the aldo fight in
the green room
no it was in the aldo fight he literally
told me he's going to i'm going to draw
him into that dead space and during this
moment i'll walk him into this and did
you see him in the group that video of
him
he's telling his coach this is what's
gonna happen he's come forward i'm gonna
check and he's gonna be over and they're
like dude focus on the fight he's like
no i am this is the fight yeah this is
the
yeah have you ever heard of him now ever
now in any sport and it's rare and wild
and it's a moment and he he was process
driven right like he was like it was
about
becoming more than he was it wasn't
about winning winning would be a
consequence of of training and practice
right and also look how kind of just
talk to them yeah like the the the
smoothness it's like butter dude even
just
you know offering different things there
he knocked out aldo and others with that
left hand but you'll see a few times in
this one there's a double left backing
up where literally you're like oh my god
he upgraded the weapon like it's the
matrix yeah yeah it really and he's
seeing everything you know
this is more about the nervous system
than it is we'll say oh beautiful left
hand it's just a punch right it's about
the performer you know it's not a
beautiful cgd note it's a beautiful
guitar playing right as an artist like
it's it's not the punch it's the
neurology of the human right it's
incredible it really is and look at
where he is he knows where he is and he
knows where you are eddie was like i
told myself we're going to wrestle and
not box and he said like suddenly i
found myself boxing next thing he knew i
got the left knuckles in the face
that double left backing up and and it's
like so against although it's one and
against eddie it is bang bang bang like
while retreating and that's not
unheard of but it just that it's so
funny
yeah the reloading of that left hand is
unheard of dude
and it's he's it's vision too right you
see eddie too when he gets knocked down
he gets his fingers like this holy [ __ ]
that's real yeah yeah and you know and
again like i love eddie he is my one of
my true favorites with cub swanson and
connor these moments of conor mcgregor's
is trent just so special and rare let me
let me ask you this rob do we ever see
this again i maybe i don't think so
maybe not this so
so if you're conor you are not shooting
for this you're shooting for some new
version of what a wiser more experienced
human there again like and and it's just
unbelievable and again it's not about
the punch it's about the movement and
about the seeing and about the neurology
vision the
cerebral cortex
drawing the information in and getting
the motor cortex to operate in tenths of
a second
you know it's like hitting a fastball
and also his vision to analyze it in
real time and process it how fast he's
processed so it's called rapid
perceptual decision making that's what
it's called in baseball rapid perceptual
decision making where your brain is
making decisions it's it's gaining
information and it's algorithmically
analyzing it and making decisions free
of consciousness and is that because of
repetitions like the motor skills it's
the same it's like freestyle rap or jazz
improvisation or hitting a fastball the
guy who hits a fastball doesn't say it's
a fastball he doesn't use any words
because there's no time for words no
with rapid perceptual decision making
the the cerebral cortex gains
information triggers the motor cortex to
do some pre-rehearsed they call it an
engram a rehearsal that you've done so
many times your brain does it by itself
it's [ __ ] cool right this is the kind
of [ __ ] that that i get excited about
and i'm obsessed with over time you
learn these things this is that's what
it's about he's trained his neurology to
do this free of conscious thought it's
freaky it really is it's freaky it's
magical it's so crazy like this you know
what else is really wild is over time
the crazy things that
chinese martial artists and you know old
school like wushu guys used to talk
about about like being able to act
before action
you start to realize when you study the
neurology that's true you don't you
don't swing at a fastball you swing at
some precursor to a fast ball that
triggers you to go and it's the same
thing conor mcgregor is not reacting to
punches he's
his brain is reacting to precursors to
punches so you're actually acting before
you know what's happening would that be
referred to as the flow state or let's
say it being in the zone yes if you're
in the flow state this will allow this
to take place you watch the he's
watching himself perform and eddie is
thinking about performing and it's hard
for eddie right now and he knows that
he's not in a flow station no he's not
going to panic nothing's really working
he's attempted three takedowns and
eddie's a genius right who has fought
everybody and i remember eddie saying
before beforehand uh he's like the
boogeyman isn't real and in his mind
right now he's like holy [ __ ] the boogey
man is real yes right like it's
pennywise yeah yeah he's lit up and look
connor's not even sweating like this is
just weird
yeah that's the thing it's and it's a
they call it the double pulse neurology
it's tension relaxation tension in
milliseconds where it's like relax relax
back back relax and bruce lee's one-inch
punch these are all real things like
these are all real martial arts things
about high levels of performance so
you'll watch for a moment of tension
there's a moment of relaxation and then
tension again so there the moment where
the punch begins is an elastic movement
is and then the the punch itself happens
in sort of a serene relaxed state and
then it's tension again at the end yeah
i think the thing that's kind of
depressing me right now is we're never
going to see something like this again
because the business model has gone away
from this so there's still pay-per-views
but the magnitude oh my god double left
hand crazy the magnitude of this fight
mass square garden yeah conor being in
the flow state at this given time and
the greatness that he was the 145 champ
we did aldo then coming up fighting
eddie
he wrote his he created his life yeah he
created his life and on the nights he
needed to he did the things he needed to
do and that alone is really
difficult look at how relaxed he is and
eddie's like what the [ __ ] i'm really
good this guy this is like what's
happening but eddie's you know eddie's
uh
lived a life of adventure and this is
just a weird night on it and it made him
a better human and i'm glad you know
he's such a good dude i love him so much
yeah me too and he also has mark henry
in his corner who's just you know it's
mad science as a mark i love mark
but also the best beats in new jersey
but yeah he uh yeah
i think but look at this guy look at him
not even breathing hard but also
another guy who attempted this
would be
he was in the flow state yeah the bigger
guy took him down wasn't the best just
didn't have the night he just didn't
have it when on
conor mcgregor and that's okay is he's a
genius he's a brilliant martial a
wonderful martial artist and and he's
got a long career ahead of him and the
value he'll extract from that one that
didn't quite do it will be part of when
he does it
and for conor's job now when he watches
this he knows this happened he did it
this is a result of his hard work
you don't shoot to be this anymore
because it's years later your life is
different you're different you think
different you shoot to be your version
of this now whatever that
yeah
is
he has wisdom he didn't have then
life experience he has life experience
he has wisdom he has experience uh off
season be a little slower but i don't
think you get to this level where he's
at in this flow state
if you're on yachts and gucci satin
pajamas does that make sense yeah i
don't know if it's been done if it has
he has to look who has done that floyd i
guess floyd but but also floyd changes
fighting style we went from but he'll
change this too
he'll change his too he'll be completely
different when you see him back he will
be different there's no question just
knowing that too
yeah that too
nuts
but then the little bounce out and the
little bounce out because
when i when i put up taekwondo or karate
breakdown videos people are always like
you know see that's what happens when
you don't put your hands up when
somebody's smashing you that little hand
is not going to help when somebody
spinning kicks you in the head so it
becomes about
moving your head and torso and your
whole core out of the way and all the
things he's doing now they're better
than having your hands up and having
your hands down briefly allows you to be
actually more mobile yeah it's not
advised but it's it's a different god
just it's so perfect like it's so
perfect
and uh you know and eddie was a part
his performance on this night was a part
of this story forever and he was the
perfect guy for the job as tough as he
is yeah nobody else had been out of
their champion at the time a real legend
in his own right it makes it better
you know i had a hard time picking this
one when we were going to come in
because of my real love for eddie
alvarez too but but it's just so perfect
it's so tough to pick fights
the fighters always pick so we had
cheeto in here
or we'll go over some and then what i
did with eric griffin who's a comic i
didn't want to watch it with a fighter
maybe could have been filming fighter
but we watched my three biggest losses
wow i've never said that yeah wow how
did you yeah uh yeah i i honestly i
walked away sad because
hey i was losing but b
n i had nobody in my ear going hey dude
yeah slow down enjoy this moment also
don't take this fight this isn't smart
but yeah i had people in there go that's
the ufc
yeah and and live it be present in these
moments and enjoy them you're a
professional athlete live your life you
know like yeah the hearts of the biggest
see history incredible thing you know
like all you
that's the thing and i'm glad you look
at this stuck and it's just like i'm
going to end it now it's time
i'm glad and you know eddie lived
another day and has a wonderful life and
it's proud of you yeah and he's proud of
the life of who he is and what he is and
that's good and connor can look and
because he did this on this night this
level of performance on the biggest
night in the biggest arena uh he that is
infamous powerful for him um but yeah
his goal should be to be different now
it's not to re-be this it's to be what
is the version of a wise life
experienced person what can you do now
to create a comeback because you can't
you shouldn't try to be this you're not
this you're a different homicidal guy i
don't know if you bat on adam yeah so
was that uh beckham jr he was so unhappy
probably just found out you got traded
to the browns
um
but uh yeah for con
a part of me like
i really hope he figures it out yeah
nobody champions for him harder than me
i hope he figures it out and i hope he
becomes a version of himself that is
successful and gets the win and he comes
back and whatever shape that is whatever
that looks like that that he gets the
job done because he owes it to himself
and his family for sure and as a father
i think about him showing this fight to
his son yeah you think about when his
son's 12 and goes dad how good were you
he goes hey babe yes put on eddie
alvarez mad square garden and after that
we're going to watch owl yeah yeah watch
what we're going to do let's watch
mendez aldo uh
um eddie yeah
again that's how big of a connor fan
also put on the khabib fight yeah what i
want you to do is watch six khabib
fights before i fight yeah i want to see
what i want you to see without really
training without committing entirely to
this fight i want you to see how good
your dad did against and yeah the best
ever do it
look at round one yeah look at what i
did in round one and stayed calm and
stayed relaxed around four or five like
yeah people that take away because we
didn't realize how good could he was at
the time you watch that fight again
i would if we could watch today yeah you
watch that fight you're like holy [ __ ]
yeah that's the best amazing amazing
he is amazing
prepare for it yeah that's how good
connor is so there's a lot of
amazing lessons if you watch anything or
study anything you're curious about
anything and one of them is like if you
hate conor mcgregor you've got and
that's possible and it's okay you're a
person you can love and hate whatever
you want if you do you realize the
impact and if you love them same thing
any of these things we realize the
impact it has on how we'd look at the
world so if you hated me like against
khabib he got wrecked if you're like me
go actually look at that and
that those are valuable things to
understand because we do that with the
president united states and we do that
with like um
and once you realize it's you yeah you
get that's a lot of value you can get
out of watching fighting
yeah yeah exactly it's part of life
right
human body somebody for doing taking a
risk yeah and you're that that triggers
you yeah you're talking yes that's right
the reason you're upset you're throwing
these mean comments online or on forums
is because you there's something
yourself that makes for sure and
we're not mad at you for doing it
but i'd like you to be happier and you
could be happier if you figured out why
watching somebody do chase their dreams
makes you unhappy even if they say yeah
and yeah and pause and ask yourself why
does this make me unhappy and look for
look ruthlessly at yourself is it
because i'm not doing what i want is it
because i'm afraid is it because i feel
more safely in the middle of the past
yeah
when you see somebody try and fail you
can take it as evidence that should you
should have stayed in the middle of the
pack like me that's where it's safer
because people like me are going to make
fun of you yes you know who cares yeah
who cares you got to live sorry kids
last break because i'm here to tell you
about kratom listen i use kratom on
everything i do podcast tv stand up
whatever it is your boy has kratom
floating through his veins but not just
any kratom i only use happy hippo kratom
that's right i trust happy hippo it's
it's my limitless pill basically is man
it's the best focused product i've ever
used best part it's all natural daddy
it's all natural that's why i use it
they have quick shots that i can take
before i go on stage before i do a
podcast they have pills they have
gummies they got it all whatever you
prefer happy hippo got you covered you
don't want to just use any kratom
cream's the wild west you need one he
can trust you can trust my boys at happy
hippo visit happyhippo herbals.com use
promo code sickboy for 20 off for life
use that code as many times as you want
that's happy hippo herbals.com use promo
code sickboy for 20 off for life now
let's get back to the program and now
the last fight you picked this is an
instrument i mean you're obviously a
hoary fan yeah
i worked for him for his bare knuckle
show and he's great
coming up when he was fighting before he
had the darren till and all these big
moments i was doing analysis of him uh
when i was in rogan's podcast said now
we were talking about how special of a
martial artist he is when he was
sometimes winning and sometimes losing
because it isn't about just
the results it's about watching what the
artist does and i was always like this
is a rare and unique and special i think
what what made him one of the biggest
ufc stars today is he's always been this
journeyman like everyone always respect
him everyone knew he would fight whoever
whenever and then finally he got his
after the beauty and that there's where
people go oh yeah that's cool if you
know a story like oh that's cool yeah
and and again like he's on kimbo
backyard
fights i broke those down too
17 i think yeah he's a long ponytail
it's ridiculous i broke those down too
but he uh that on the other hand you can
take and go hey
if it's just committing and not giving
up and continuing to work hard even when
it's challenging sometimes you can take
that out of him you can go hey wait what
you know i'm working hard at something
in my life and it's not quite there yet
well maybe you just keep at it maybe you
just stay with it and maybe your time
will come if you uh concentrate on
getting better and being there
exactly
when your name's called if you're
prepared you put in the work and it goes
with comics you louis ck took 20 years
to pop
bill burr took 15 years to pop like but
imagine billboards so good why is he so
good because of the hard work hard work
preparation so for bill biller it was
this moment that he didn't realize we're
going to blow him up you know they're
doing this big comedy show and all these
great comics it's in philly and the
comics can roast again booed and then
burrs up and burr goes i'm gonna flip
the script i'm gonna go at them i'll
make fun of their city i make fun of the
freaking statue i'm gonna do all this
stuff and then that was his moment
oh this guy's hilarious yeah he won the
crowd and he relaxed and he just did it
yeah but before that is
how many hours i mean yeah 30 000 hours
at that point actually it's fascinating
to mention that we always talk about
mastery is ten thousand hours you start
to realize later it's like there's a
different level at twenty thousand
correct and there's another level at
thirty thousand you don't get there and
then now i'm good i'll just chill the
goal is to be
to see what you're capable of to
actualize your potential before you die
and let your kids see you doing that so
they'll do that that's the [ __ ] goal
going back to the first fight holly holm
yeah anything about how many times she
threw that freaking head kick yeah over
the years over non-stop to for this
moment that prepared her for rhonda to
turn her back and then knock her out as
a plus 700 under exactly exactly
and jorge same thing all his life noth
and that was i it's a term
you know
i like to just riff and let
ideas come out but there are sometimes i
go back to the odd thing and one of them
i like to use is birds fly fish swim
jorge mouse with all fights men in cages
all right yeah and he said that to me
one day and uh years and years and years
ago and i just thought it was brilliant
he was like saying i'm not trying to be
a fighter i'm not learning frightened
this is what i am it's all he knows
right and so i'll use that occasionally
and i'll drop somebody else's name in
there not out of disrespect to the this
brilliant martial artist just because
it's a cool thing i said that about
fedor once and i like to it's a nice
thing to say and often i'll then credit
him when joe rogan says [ __ ] on the ufc
he'll say shout out to robin black it's
the kindest thing that's so cool the
kindest thing in the world uh and so
i'll try to do that with him but
yeah corey muzzle been asking this was
the instrument because if people
remember me nobody championed ben askin
more than me and joe wrote we for years
were begging dana to get him in the ufc
so watch where he's leaning watch his
his nonverbal body language his
nonverbals watch jorge there's ben watch
jorge there's a very nice celeste yep
yep
watch him now okay chill arms down watch
he's going to lean back with his hands
behind his back
you went okay that is a nonverbal
indication that if
that you shouldn't yeah you shouldn't be
concerned
right the the knee is brilliant you're
talking [ __ ] yeah yeah and and that's
him right like i don't judge that that's
organically exactly i have no judgment
for that no there's a lot of hype going
into the fight yeah
man when you talk about top
three knockouts yeah yeah everything
ever and it changed his life you know he
was but so the the knee the the double
knee is brilliant but it's this
that's what created that moment meaning
they indicated that i'm not going to run
into a flying knife
getting badass
yes yes it it it is he it's art of war
stuff
um there i forget the line but it's like
when
when you're far make him think you're
close when you close make him think
you're far away when you're inactive
make him think you're active so i think
that was a yeah
100 that was strategized wow also you'll
see jorge
yeah yeah and they'll show it again when
he leans back against the cage with his
hands behind his back he is sending
non-verbal communication that you
shouldn't be too concerned right now and
it's it is one hundred percent
calculated one is one
i know right that's an art of war it's a
true look at
that's the moment that when he's leaning
on the cage that created the whole thing
and and that to me that's the genius of
martial artistry and that's the wisdom
when we're talking you know and there's
a pump so and when ben goes to take him
down and people say well you know and we
see it often when you see a flying knee
you'll see a guy in the middle of a
takedown and actually the brain will
default it's sort of like when a guy
goes to catch a ball and the sun's in
his eyes the brain will default to
whatever it's programmed to do and
shooting for a double leg takedown
during a knee is a weird fart of the
brain but you see it all the time and
it's not because some guy's stupid or
why does it go through a takedown it's
because the brain just did that and it's
gonna do that yeah wow yeah and it does
that it doesn't know how to process the
information so it does the thing you've
done your whole life and so
in those seconds you've got jorge's
misdirection art of war inactive and
seeming active you've got the brain
reacting to something
in an unpredictable moment that it's
unprepared for it there's so much
happening in those seconds yeah six
seconds
and who's the guy that jorge punched in
the back room is that leon edwards so
same thing
i broke that one down before the soda
when he's walking over to him he's got
his hand on the on the thing doing the
same thing same thing and i remember i
broke it down and some guy from the ufc
was like you better take that and he's
texting me that i got to take that down
i'm like why and he goes because you
don't want espn after you and i'm like
wait a second this isn't even yours
uh and i just took it down yeah yeah i
did because i was like
no they killed it back up
they killed my facebook like they
attacked they no they killed it i had
103 000 followers on instagram they
killed it forever oh yeah and and again
talking about joe and how much she's
done for me joe put up a post and said
please follow my friend robin black he
got killed by the ufc which i don't
agree with actually was this fight with
the final one i showed this
from the stands how many people 53 000
oh wow yeah yeah so i got half of it wow
the others i had to uh to earn one at a
time i think what else i think what else
is a shame on this so fast knock down
ufc history five seconds the other
i mean kudos to mazdal the other shame
on this is ben askren to your point
people will bring this up or yes bring
out the other knockouts jake paul or
whatever whatever and in no way
undermines the greatness of ben affleck
and they people don't understand
remember but also ben asking at this
time is coming he had to have hip
surgery he had
he's older here this isn't ben asking
his prime ben asking his prime is a
world champion yes undefeated ask
anybody who's trained with a woodley
yeah freaking uh you you brilliant uh
auntie pettis yeah nobody nobody on this
planet could roll with bennett his funky
style was unstoppable but then he gets
the ufc and it was too you know almost
late yeah yeah it was late yeah yeah but
it was good for him he's got a funny
sense of humor and he lived it's sort of
like also really smart yeah smart
different
yeah and so he did it is his way and
unfortunately this happened but in no
way undermines him and if it does to
some people that can't matter to ben it
can matter to you it can't matter to
anyone living out there trying to chase
their thing it can't matter you have to
learn i don't know anyone doing their
own thing like trying to be successful
that would throw shade on ben
even flatters that jake paul for
instance yeah
zero analysis yeah
yeah for sure and uh yeah and and but
this was the night changed jorge's life
forever and he earned it and he stayed
with it and he kept fighting he kept
focusing he kept training there's joe uh
and uh you know he he became this and he
he earned this he made this for himself
now top five biggest names in the ufc
yeah i don't know what's next for him
especially with the colby
yeah i wish he didn't sucker punch him
yeah i love
even though i think kobe did cross the
line yeah i just can't respect the
sucker but i want
we don't know right like so we we don't
know actually what happens okay he's
saying that it was mutual and i don't
know if that's the case somebody said he
ran up then somebody he will he will
make him he will make a point
in
in court i'm sure that this was actually
much more mutual than that i will land
on this you know i do it from the ufc i
tell kobe
um
hey man drop the charges because if you
don't and he's going to go to prison so
we're going to lose one of our biggest
review stars drop the charges you guys
can settle this on a pay-per-view and
we'll give you more pay-per-view points
but you got to drop the charges because
even if you beat jorge we can still have
them fight whoever yeah
nick diaz there's a fight huge fight and
nick diaz yeah
so from the ufc i go hey drop the
charges yeah we'll make it up to you
here we'll give you more pay-per-view
bonus points beat them in real life and
the build-ups would be fantastic you
also got those a couple of things one
boom if he goes to jail for four months
just make his legend bigger right and
horizontal dude that bug shot i'll put
it up here yeah yeah it'll make his
legend bigger
it's because of who he is and how he
lives and how he sees the world and the
code that he lives by it'll be like a
hip-hop guy going to jail yep you know
what i mean so but it sucks because
you're in jail for three months or
whatever i feel like but on the other
hand you do have to ask yourself how who
do i want to be what do i want my story
to be and for colby do i want my story
to be that i created a bunch of nonsense
did some crazy [ __ ] that i that i said
to myself was okay because it was going
to make me more money and make me more
stuff and then when i did that i
provoked something there was
consequences and i went to the police is
that what you want your story to be
because that's up to you and then also
to to add on to that you guys were
friends man you guys were roommates so
there's a history there you know you
press charges come on yeah yeah exactly
nobody's respected yeah no exactly and
dude i don't know what jorge did i don't
respect what colby's doing i think
there's somewhere where they can meet in
the middle yeah you hope you hope so and
you know it's almost and we'll end on
this it's almost like what's going on
with cain velasquez now your father
it's just if you're a dad and see you
it's so heartbreaking
i hope it goes to a jury because the the
judge is
looks at kane like a human [ __ ] fighter
right older judge female and that's not
what we want but it's going to go to a
jury you have to hope that jury has
someone have kids yeah because they're
going to go oh we can understand how he
had a
a bit of rage when he found out what
happened and this isn't him because
32 years prior to that
a one of the the faces of the ufc face
of mexican-american culture
outstanding person yeah outstanding
father captain of aka so it's like
so he had one bad moment so yeah so
you're gonna put him away for how long
also yeah you put him away now his kids
grow up without a doubt he's like how
long 15 years minimum yeah so it's like
how many lives do you want to ruin if
you go
and ask 500 people who are fathers if
someone hurt their somebody close in
their family their child whatever what
would they do and half of them would be
like i wouldn't want to kill somebody
and go to jail and and deprive my uh my
children of a father but i think i would
do it yes when i imagine somebody's
harming my daughter right now i would
kill them and and i'm not i don't feel
comfortable saying that but i know that
i'm speaking the truth
to decide that yeah and that's what's
going to happen hopefully it's all right
but uh dude we could do this and we'll
do it again yeah you're the best one
yeah man it's been so good yeah you're
the best man keep doing your thing keep
being original man you're the best in
the game best ever do it brother you
know this
all right robin black everybody
a little bit of work man that don't
scare us i get up i go hard like i'm
george harris make plays break lanes
push break chains go hard kick ass take
names